I'll speak from my perspective as a researcher
who works in robotics, machines, and manufacturing
systems.
But a lot of infrastructure gets developed
that is owned by specific entities.
Like you have Boston Dynamics that does really
cool robots for example.
They don't release in the public domain how
to build their robots.
You can buy a robot from them and use it as
a platform, but you can't BE the platform.
And so at the same time, right now if you
look at deep learning frameworks, you have
CNTK from Microsoft, or TensorFlow from Google,
or any of the other ones.
Which one is going to be the framework and
can you BE that framework, or do you just
have to buy into that system?
Are they a monopoly?
So if we all have to buy into TensorFlow,
which is owned by Alphabet/Google, then what
does that mean for what direction, what does
that mean for the politics of the infrastructure?
And I think that in the case of Boston Dynamics,
most of their funding came from federal agencies,
DARPA or the Department of Defense.
And so why is that infrastructure owned by
them?
Why is that platform owned by them?
In the case of Google, they're pouring in
their own resources to build their own platform.
So it makes sense that they want to retain
ownership over it.
But are there other places where researchers
like us can exercise insight into the design
of infrastructural systems such that they
remain democratic platforms, or become democratic
platforms?
If you're driving for Uber, you have to use
the Uber app, but can you also just fork the
Uber app instead?
And be the Uber?
That kind of idea but for AI infrastructure.